哈囉大家好 我是阿迪
今天呢要來跟大家分享一個
甜感非常非常高的一個手沖手法
不甜不好喝
我們喝咖啡呢
要的就是什麼
就是喝起來甜
香氣也要夠
最好呢就是口感也要厚實
這些好像阿米水長話
很像
那我們知道我們在手沖咖啡的時候
大致上風味的順序是從
香氣然後酸質
然後再來甜感
然後最後會來到一些
看苦味啊
那所以呢我這次呢
會希望說在手沖上面可以多集中在填感的部分
那我們這次選用的濾杯是
那個PureX的幽浮濾杯
為什麼會選幽浮濾杯呢
就是幽浮濾杯是我目前覺得用起來流速算順暢的
那其實你如果要用V60也是OK
就是剛好現在幽浮濾杯在我們這邊有九折的優惠
如果你有興趣的話
我們會把那個購物連結放在底下
幽浮濾杯還有它夏湖AURA這個光道理咖啡層
都有久折的優惠
這次的咖啡呢要20克
好 我們就用這個
這是前一陣子從國外買回來的咖啡豆
那個紅色很好看耶
很美啊 超美的
而且你看這個包裝
而且我跟你說
但它是不是空運折到
對
這有點爛掉 底下爛掉
但沒關係啦
它的包裝非常有質感
因為有些包裝質它就會比較軟
它上面是不是有牙花
對 需要打開
這個烘豆廠是美國的叫做
O-N-Y-X
念念看
O-N-O-N-X嗎
O-N-X
總之是美國知名的烘豆廠
這次拿到的豆子是
肯亞很香耶乘20克這樣子就不會了
好
看你可不可以一次驕傲到最後
他們都沒有用
蜜蜂條啊
他們可能就是一天多香味
然後一個禮拜就放夠才會完
所以他們不需要保鮮
也是
喔對啊
啊?
蜜蜂袋
蜜蜂袋是什麼
研磨度可以稍微粗一點點
不用太細
因為等一下我們會分三段注水
如果你研磨度太細的話
我怕流速會很慢
所以盡量不要太細
等一下我們會分一段門針
然後三段給水
Warner用92度
它的那個莓果味很重
真的喔
很香耶
很像它的包裝顏色
對
有這個感覺
就莓果調
好,92度
一開始就給40克的水
20克的粉
然後給40克的水
盡量讓每一個粉塵都有吃到水
然後就要用30到30秒
那這個悶蒸呢
可以30秒到45秒隨便
就依照你自己的粉的排氣狀況
那新鮮是要40還是新鮮要才5
如果它排氣狀況很好的話
就可以放久一點
就是它可能到40秒都還在排氣像這個我覺得應該35秒40秒就差不多了然後第二柱呢我們要用比較大的水量去給到100cc
所以呢
總共
你會來到
兩
會來到140
然後可以稍微往外繞
八分
吹開
好
然後等水流完
這一柱呢我們要用比較小的水
然後拉長這一段的萃取時間
可以中間稍微往外繞
水不要太強
一樣給100cc
那這一百CC呢我們就會來到240cc
然後一樣等它流完
然後等下最後一段呢
我們要給60克的水
那這60克的水呢
我們可以用比較大的水柱去灌它
到300CC這樣子
所以是1比15
對 1比15 左右
好 一樣等水流完就可以喝了
那這次沖煮大概是落在2分20秒左右
那我覺得這個手法在2分半都還算合理啦
如果你想要時間再短一點的話
要嘛就換個流速更快的濾杯
不然就把研磨度再調得更粗
那它整體的時間就會再往前
好 那我們最後喝看看喔
嗯很香超甜你喝它看而且不太会有杂味
对不对
很甜哦
好喝
而且这个豆子也不错
它其实不酸
对啊
它有前段的一点点的果汁感
我觉得它确实就是比较偏美果
不是感觉的那种酸
然后这个手法会比较再往后段一点点
所以會有很多的甜感
然後口感也會比較厚實
上次VV咖啡學長
他就在講說
你這個手法很危險
就這個手法真的蠻危險的
你只要擦一點點
可能鹽粉太細
或是你的濾杯就堵塞
就是它的濾杯流速不穩定的話
它很有可能就整個都苦掉
然後整個味道都吃得掉
但如果抓得好的話
它就變超甜
好喝
這個好喝
那這個手法就分享給大家
就是你如果覺得你的味道怎麼沖
都太酸
然後或是太淡的話
你可以試試看這個
就是比較甜度比較高
然後口感比較厚實的這個手法
然後可以修正你的時間
就讓你的那個給水次數
沖可能兩次
變三次或四次
然後就可以讓整個味道往後段萃去
那就会比较多的甜感和口感
那如果大家还有什么其他想看我们分享的手法
后来都可以在底下留言
或者说你在手冲上面碰到什么问题
也可以在底下留言
然后我们就会之后再找一个时间来拍影片回应大家
或者是呢也可以从IG私讯跟我们讲
我们都会看得到
那我们下次见咯
拜拜